we have a voicemail number the number is
two one nine two david p received a
voicemail about reparations for black
americans let's take a listen hi David
it's Mike calling and I was wondering
well I watched the congressional hearing
about reparations and he's very
interesting dialogue and I'm generally
supportive of the idea of reparations
but I do think that the conversation
going on right now does have the
potential to backfire against the
eventual Democratic nominee and it has
potential to ignite the far right and it
is just generally unpopular with the
wider American people although I do
think that we can make the argument for
it so thank you yeah listen I don't know
about the popularity of reparations for
black Americans among the broader
American people I've not seen polling
about that here's my view on it I think
that there is a very valid and
completely reasonable moral and
philosophical debate to be had about
reparations for black Americans how many
generations after slavery does it go how
do you demonstrate that you are actually
descended from individuals that were
slaves in the United States rather than
from families that came to the United
States after slavery was abolished I'm
totally up for having that discussion in
practice unless Democrats get a
supermajority in the Senate I don't see
any way any way that reparations pass
and thus I believe that in 2019 right
now this is a distraction of a
conversation and I believe that it is
not a pragmatically
smart path for Democrats at large to go
down that that's that's my view I don't
see any way that you get a single
Republican when it comes down to voting
in the Senate or maybe more than three
or four Republicans I just don't see any
way forward for this and as a result I
don't think that it's particularly smart
politics to keep talking about this at
this point in time if you disagree I do
want to hear from you
we will talk on the bonus show today
about how Bernie Sanders would cancel
student loan debt and much much more
including how Trump advisor Kellyanne
Conway is straight-up going to not show
up to the Hatch Act hearing that has
been scheduled get an instant access to
the bonus show by becoming a member or a
patron I will speak to you then